well congratulations already a season to
pick up yes yeah we must have done
something right so it's not more
pressure with the expectations higher or
is that just now you breathe a sigh of
relief I tend to exist in a sphere of
pressure and I I never use pressure as a
negative influence on me I always use as
a positive influence if pressure is
applied then I take that as a sign that
I need to double my work effort and so
it's for me it's always a positive this
show is already being compared to Game
of Thrones how do you feel about those
comparisons flattering very flattering
Game of Thrones was a fantastic show I
know there were there was some disc
there was some discontent about the last
season but as far as a show goes
enormous ly successful and very very
popular and fantastically performed and
so for me it's it's very flattering of
course Game of Thrones and The Witcher
are very different products we are
talking yes they both exist within a
fantasy genre but one of them aside from
some dragons is very much
reality based there's a there's it's all
about royal politics essentially and The
Witcher while politics is a massive
issue and it's definitely existing in a
world of politics it's a world of
monsters and magic and so the two Contin
aside from the fact that they exist
within the same genre albeit at
different end of the spectrum now your
look in the widget what was it like when
you transformed and then you look in the
mirror and you see yourself did you
recognise yourself you it's a good
question actually now that I think about
it to a degree
no when I looked in the mirror after the
ladies had done all their hard work
Alvar and Jackie had finished my makeup
of my hair it was a very different
person I was looking at and that was
extraordinarily helpful that is what I
wanted I wanted Geralt to look like
geralt and Geralt does look very
different from everyone else which is
one of the reasons why he's ostracized
and hated as soon as he walks into a
village and for me that was a good thing
I it was a transformation and it
I helped my performance lots of training
I imagine on this how did it compare to
training for Superman its training is
training regardless evil is evil Strega
for training is training and regardless
of where where you're doing it what kind
of training are doing what you're trying
to achieve it's difficult the most
difficult thing is time is fitting
training into a working day and into a
working shoot so for me it was very
similar it's it's always that taxation
of time and and you push through you do
it because it's for the role and and you
enjoy it especially when it pays off
when you're having a shirtless Sina when
you're doing an action scene which
requires a certain amount of physicality
to get through especially on a TV show
you have less time to shoot the action
it's it was extraordinarily helpful and
so I'm happy I did it
are we gonna see you as Superman again
you'll have to wait and see
you